Nim a general purpose systems
programming language that can deliver
high performance native apps with
concise elegant code it was created by
Andreas rump in Germany in 2005 who
wanted a language with the performance
of C the productivity of Python and the
extensibility of lisp like other systems
languages Nim is statically typed and
compiled however it's Unique because its
source code is first translated to a
different language usually C then uses a
compiler like clang to convert it to
machine code and it can also transpile
to C plus plus Objective C and even
JavaScript by default it uses a
deterministic memory management strategy
based on reference counting but this
Behavior can be customized or removed
altogether allowing low-level control
over memory with pointers syntactically
it feels like a statically typed python
but it also provides extensive support
for meta programming with a macro system
that allows direct access to the
abstract syntax tree allowing you to
mold the language to your exact needs
much like the list family of languages
to get started install an on your
machine then create a new file ending in
dot Nim unlike C no main function is
necessary use Echo to print to the
standard output or create a variable
with the VAR keyword and follow it with
an optional type annotation variables
can be reassigned but we can make them
single assignment with let or use cons
to make the assigned value immutable
when writing a complex statement like an
if condition indentation matters like
python this keeps the code nice and
readable like when declaring multiple
variables for Loops it has a variety of
built-in iterators like count up and
countdown or you can use the iterator
keyword along with yield to build your
own from scratch to Define functions or
methods we use procedures which can take
input arguments and return a value it
also supports closures and using
procedures as arguments or return values
for functional programming patterns
however it's also possible to use object
oriented patterns by first creating a
complex type which can then be
instantiated like a class and it also
supports generics allowing you to use
types as parameters what makes Nim
really special though is its support for
meta programming for example we can get
the abstract syntax tree at any time
using dumptree with this information we
can now write our own macros which are
like functions that modify the abstract
syntax tree at compile time it's like
writing Nim code that writes more Nim
code for you now open the terminal and
use the compiler to convert your Nim
code into C and then into a machine code
executable or use the JS command to
transpile it to JavaScript this has been
Nim in 100 seconds hit the like button
if you want to see more short videos
like this thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one